protests in thailand have entered their
second month
activists feel the military dominates
too much of the government and that the
country has slid
further and further away from democracy
what's different this time from previous
protests over the years
has also been the call to reform the
country's monarchy
while the people protest thai king
vajiralongkorn has reportedly spent
much of the pandemic at a luxury hotel
in southern germany
protesters want to limit the king's
power his finances and
they want to have the right to criticize
him something they can't do
under thailand's strict laws at the
moment
a tribute to democracy ripped away and
disappeared
a whodunit near bangkok's royal palace
less than 24 hours earlier protest
leaders had installed this plaque
engraved with the message thailand
belongs to the people
authorities say they're pressing charges
over this bold challenge
to the thai king on paper thailand has a
constitutional monarchy
but criticism often leads to prison
now the taboo has been broken and the
call is out
for limits on royal power
we are not demanding an end to the
monarchy
we want reform with good intentions
that would keep the monarchy graciously
above the people
under democratic rule
and their demands for reform don't stop
there
protesters want the military-backed
prime minister prayut chanocha
to step down new elections and a new
constitution
i'm here to protest the government an
authoritarian regime
they're both part of what's wrong
i think it's the first step of victory
because people knows
people have already walked
protesters marched their demands to the
king's privy council
police blocked the way but agreed to
deliver the letter
[Music]
now to keep up pressure organizers are
calling for a boycott
of the bank where the king is the
largest shareholder and a general strike
next month a bid to tap into the power
the people already have
joining us is janjira sumbapun suri
political scientist with the institute
of asian studies
at shillong corn university gender it
seems as if the protests are picking up
momentum is that your sense and where do
you think it's going
well definitely i think the protests are
getting better bigger and bigger by the
day
and i think that the political momentum
is on their side
and they are going to have another
protest in october
um and i think it will gather more
people
and are people protesting more against
the military or more
against the monarchy and and why
difficult to differentiate between the
two um
i would put it this way that this is the
same
regime and um the people are protesting
against
this regime and i think
um the the issue of the monarchy has
served because of a a group
within the movements and so um
with under that movement there are
several groups and i think
in the next protest um a different group
would take charge and probably that
would change
the topic of discussion so we'll see
um how the the topic would change
next month one thing i'm wondering about
is whether these protests are different
from any of the protests we've seen over
the past
decade in thailand are they different
um i mean if you put this protest in the
context
of uh for example the red and yellow
church
um in the past 10 years they are
definitely different
um they what they want is to change the
whole system they do not want fi
tuning reforms any superficial change
they want um the change
of the system and i think they have
become more
um uh in the sense uncompromising
but also very patient as they know that
this is a long struggle and it will not
they will not achieve their goal easily
in the terms of uh changing the system
but so they are ready to wear for a long
long struggle
so what they want to do is change the
system
give us some context in terms of how
conditions in thailand got to where they
are
today that people are on the streets
well i mean in a nutshell um
thailand as society has changed but
the political system has not changed to
accommodate that
and right now we are seeing the clash
between parts of the society that
want to move forward and the other part
of society
who that want to stay the same and
preserve
the status quo and so um i think this
is the bottom line of the whole conflict
and
um in the past we've seen tit-for-tat
protests between supporters
of the old ideas and supporters of the
new ideas
and right now this is supporters of the
new idea so
i'm not sure if the momentum has
completely shifted
to the supporters of the new idea um
if not then we may see another
mobilization
of supporters of the old ideas
janjira sumbat punsuri thank you
you